there steve kaufman here
uh it's nighttime uh getting closer to
christmas
and um i thought i'd talk about
something that
caught my attention uh just the other
day uh it was the news that angelina
jolie
wants to study french
i think i remember doing something not
too long ago where she said she was
studying russian or something
at any rate she wants to study french
she claims that her kids and she's got
quite a few i hadn't realized just how
many kids she has
uh but her kids speak french apparently
her mother
is a french canadian ancestry
and so angelina is determined to learn
french
which i think is very laudable
and i think she could uh she could
probably do a a great job on french i
think actors and and actresses
um are natural language learners because
they're used to the idea that they have
to project themselves
into another role they have to believe
they're someone else
so
i think she could she could certainly do
it
if she gets hung up with learning
grammar and the like that'll only delay
her progress
if she exposes herself to a lot of
interesting content
she should do quite well
and
in her case
she probably has access to
um
the uh transcripts of a lot of you know
popular movies in french that she might
want to watch
uh maybe she should um
you know uh try to get a role in a
french movie where she would have to
study
uh you know the uh the script and and
and at least learn her part so she would
know that very well
um she's probably if she is again as an
actress she's probably good at imitating
and and projecting herself into another
personality
i would advise her though not just to
learn to say things as in in a movie but
also to raise the overall level of her
familiarity with the language and her
vocabulary by doing a lot of listening
and reading so that eventually she would
be able to conduct an interesting
conversation with people uh you know she
probably travels in different circles
not probably she does travel in
different circles than i do she gets
invited to yachts that ply the
mediterranean that stop into uh you know
kan and nice and monte carlo and and it
would be fun then for her to be able to
carry on in french with all the people
that that she meets
so we would love to have her as a
learner at link
and i would be of course quite willing
to spend my own personal time in helping
her
uh with french and helping her
understand link and i wish her the best
of luck in uh in her efforts to learn
french and i'll be following up to see
how things go and if i do get a phone
call from her saying that she wants to
join link you'll be the first to hear at
my youtube channel
thank you for listening bye for now